[Musique]
natalia vient de karkhiv dont le nom
reste de l'ukraine pour arriver dans ce
centre de réfugiés en pologne elle a dû
prendre quatre trains deux jours de
voyage très éprouvant pour elle sa belle
mère et sa mère elle qu'un slip moment
l'oms
a trompé
le slip a little bit
parce
que notre ligue 1 les coins sombres
[Musique]
non dès ce matin philippe
natalia aura mis plus d'un mois à
convaincre sa mère et sa belle-mère de
fuir les deux vieilles dames ne voulait
pas quitter karkhiv son mari est lui
resté sur place avec sa voiture ils
transportent des personnes et des
médicaments dans une ville bombardée
sans relâche
sow est en
synchro festif
de phosphore
century est un soft power
[Musique]
natalia est né en union soviétique
sa mère est ukrainienne son père russe
jamais elle n'aurait pu croire que les
russes sont prendre et à kharkhiv
brassens pic se situe
vers 13h
dès que sa mère aura obtenu son visa
elles prendront la direction de
l'angleterre
où des amis les attentes
la plupart des personnes restent ici
deux ou trois jours
450 lits sont à disposition les réfugiés
peuvent trouver des produits d'hygiène
des douches de quoi s'habiller et une
laverie chaque réfugié chaque volontaire
porte au poignet un bracelet
un médecin et une infirmière sont là
pour les recevoir 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 le docteur réservé aux as
s'est porté volontaire
l'ukraine est un pays qu'il connaît bien
il y a étudié la médecine pendant six
ans
une dizaine de volontaires et là tous
les jours pour tenter d'aider et de
réconforter s'est réfugié il arrive pour
la plupart perdu et désorienté ioulia et
ukrainienne elle a quitté kiev le 28
février depuis elle est bénévole dans ce
centre
insite
[Musique]
bref on a l'état d'esprit tu veilles de
fêtes
marina aussi espère qu'un jour elle
pourra rentrer en ukraine en attendant
elle ira à berlin avec ses deux filles
elle aura mis plus de 48 heures pour
rejoindre la pologne depuis a pris déjà
confiance aux jeunes aux jeunesses
coline serreau
douaniers territory maryse mais c'est à
peu près d'un quart des services
pour tous pour que tout djediat comme
importe si je venais péter shihri et 2
pour mac do je venais
dans les collines vertes
la pologne est le pays d'europe qui
accueille le plus de réfugiés depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine soit près
de 3 millions de personnes dont la
grande majorité sont des femmes et des
enfants